[Music]
I'm very pleased to welcome Adam chapada
from MIT today and his two students as
well Ben and Clara were here visiting
Adam is going to tell us about Fiat
crypto which is a way to produce
efficient low-level cryptographic code
sort of like instruction from from
high-level specs okay thanks
and let me say I'm very glad to have
questions throughout the talk not just
at the end so what's the deal with this
Fiats cryptography stuff well I'll give
the initial setting here which I'm sure
many of you know working on very similar
things but let me just give the cartoon
picture of what it is to use the TLS
protocol to initiate a HTTP web
connection so here's the web browser
there's a web server web server has a
public key and a certificate that have
been signed by some authority to tell
you whoever knows that private key
really is the company they claim to be
so the web browser wants to initiate a
connection with the web server so a key
exchange protocol is used to establish
some secret that that only these two
parties know that is a symmetric key and
then we need to check that the browser
needs to check it's talking to the
server it meant to talk to so the
certificate and public key are retrieved
and then we use a digital signature
algorithm for the server to to prove
that you know that the party you were
just talking to to learn that symmetric
key well it must be the following
company that maybe you were talking to
and now from that point on we can just
use symmetric key crypto which is
generally a lot cheaper than then public
key crypto so every single HTTPS
connection that that goes on needs to do
go through this little dance to
establish the symmetric key the first
two stages of that process that use
public key cryptography they only run
once per session but there can be many
HTTP connections coming into a serious
data center so it's it's important to
optimize the performance of the public
key part as well and the challenges
there have to do with with trading off
between correctness and performance
and in fact the public key algorithms
and practice are a lot harder to
implement correctly and and prove
correct than the private key algorithms
and one of the biggest challenges here
is doing big integer arithmetic modulo
some huge prime number and that is what
we're going to try to get right with
with programming tool support so how bad
can it be to do arithmetic after all
well there are not that many different
crypto libraries use widely luckily and
they're built by pretty competent people
but they really have their work cut out
for them because there's a whole space
of algorithms that matter in practice
for cryptography there's another space
of different prime moduli that matter
for implementing these algorithms and
then there as usual they're a bunch of
different hardware architectures it is
surprisingly close in practice true when
I say that every element of this
three-way Cartesian product gets
implemented separately with no code
sharing and only a relatively small set
of experts on the planet know how to do
it in a way that achieves acceptable
performance so when you change the prime
number it really is true the experts
rewrite the assembly code from scratch
for every hardware architecture to get
the best performance this is the state
of practice and they get it wrong decent
fraction of the time we we found a quite
a few bug tracker issues that were
related to getting this kind of
arithmetic wrong for different kinds of
protocols so there's a real opportunity
here to improve the development to old
story for this space here's an example
of someone getting something wrong this
was a comment a reference C code written
by the same people who designed the the
primitive that it's implementing they
left a comment saying I'm not really
sure if this variable can be negative or
not you should probably go read this
book and if you figure out that it could
be negative let us know fix it here so
that's not exactly confidence enhancing
and it comes from this very cleverly
named online benchmarking comparison
site called Supercop that has this of
course
completely rational expansion down here
at the bottom this is what everyone uses
for benchmarking cryptography code
another bug by the same people again
with the reference implementation
essentially of their own algorithms they
invented what was they run about 10,000
lines of assembly code manually to get
the the expected level of performance
and oops they faced wrote r1 when they
meant r2 in one place and this meant
that the code was incorrect there was
also a bug in open SSL that involved a
disagreement about the the contract
being the caller and callee of I a
divide with remainder kind of operation
and whoops the people who found and
analyzed this bug computed that using at
least dumb random testing the chances of
finding the bugs or something like 10 to
the 2 to the negative 29 there are a lot
of corner cases to worry about in this
kind of code not always obvious what
they are so testing is not super
effective at catching problems that can
have serious security consequences so
let's try to do better
our project is Fiat cryptography it
here's a cool logo made by professional
designer in the context of our larger
project science of deep specification
which is a multi University initiative I
don't know how many people recognize the
Spy vs spy iconography here it's a
classic comic strip and the Spy has
become a rooster because we use the
proof assistant so it's a natural match
so what is this project well let me tell
the general story of how correct by
construction of cryptography might work
and then tell you which parts this
project deals with so we let's say we
have some abstract security property
like if you're able to produce a
signature fast enough then you must have
known the secret key we might do
protocol verification to show that a
particular mathematical algorithm
written at a relatively high level truly
provides that security property and we
might do implementation verification or
synthesis to show that the actual
performance low-level code is a correct
realization of that mathematical
algorithm this project is only the
second of these deuce
though we'd be very interested in
connecting to results of the first kind
and we're doing some preliminary work
along those lines now so let me zoom in
on the second part so we have a
mathematical algorithm where we're
working in particular on something
called elliptic curve cryptography which
is what's typically used for those first
stages of TLS that I talked about so
we're in algebraic structures with
two-dimensional points to start out with
and it turns out that in practice to two
dimensional points are implemented with
points in more dimensions because it is
faster and it helps you avoid the
processor instructions that are the slow
ones to introduce extra points in a way
that is largely orthogonal to what I'll
be mostly talking about so I won't say
more about it here but then we have
basically two functional programs one
that uses the simple representation
other that uses the fancy representation
and we proved that the second one is a
correct implementation of the abstract
data type that the first one defines
then we need to take the individual
coordinates of these points which are
big integers in a prime modular prime
field and we need to show that we're
correctly implementing integers so that
they're so big they don't fit in single
hardware registers we need to define
divide one number across multiple
registers and that's what that's the
really the heart of what we're doing
here so we've proved an abstraction
relation about the implementation of
single integers within the points as
multiple roughly machine word sized
pieces and then we do we take particular
choices of how to split a number into
multiple parts and then we specialize
our library of code to the particular
choices you've made to get idiomatic C
like code that is customized to those
choices and we also do abstract
interpretation to infer bit widths of of
temporaries and assign them to the
appropriately sized registers and local
variables the and our compiler for that
last part is proved correct once and for
all where whereas some of the earlier
stages are proof generating instead of
verified so several people in this room
have been doing very closely related
things so let me give the comparison
with with them the most closely related
projects that I know about so there's
the the Hackl star project which is an
NF star based crypto library using using
low star bail which Chris has been
working on doing meta programming to
build this kind of code and reason about
the code generators using Daphne and
there's a project called Jasmine which
is basically a verified compiler for a
low-level language that is appropriate
for photography
so a quick summary of the advantages of
those projects over what I'm talking
about here I showed you a few steps and
said we only do some of them well these
other projects are doing more of the
other steps at least as I as I
understand things and they're their
results are pushed all the way down to
assembly code in some cases and we are
currently stopping at a higher level
roughly C code level and also the
project I'll be presenting finishes up
generating just straight line code no
control flow and these others all have
have stories for a control flow some of
the the the pros of our approach are
that we have a much smaller trusted code
base we're doing the usual thing
where we don't have to trust SMT solvers
or compilers or any of that and more
fundamentally we are showing complete
automation of regenerating a protocol or
a primitive actually when you change
what is the prime modulus for your
arithmetic it sounds innocuous but in
practice this is what implementers spend
most of the time doing when you change
the prime modulus rewrite all the code
our compiler does it automatically
and we also regain the advantage we're
used to since the 80s of we have
compilers that retarget to new hardware
architectures automatically it turns out
and I'll show an example soon this code
is completely rewritten for each new
architecture and the state of practice
so our compiler generalizes over both
those dimensions and rebuild stuff for
you automatically when you change either
one given that there are a few people in
the room whose work I'm comparing
against any questions at this point
okay all right so it's a good thing we
good thing we kept away alright so in
other words one dimension of variation
and code in the space is the different
prime moduli that we're doing our
arithmetic with another is all the
hardware architectures out there there's
a whole space of reasonable combinations
of these and we are going to let you
pick any of those points automatically
generate code with a proof of
correctness with respect to pretty
simple whiteboard level math about
elliptic curves and we ran some
experiments I'll get through later but
in terms of how have we really
demonstrated that we have good coverage
of this space we've done experiments on
about 80 different primes on this axis
and on this one we did the usual thing
of 64-bit x86 and 32-bit arm running on
an Android phone and we get pretty good
code for almost all the the elements of
this cross-product space what does the
code look like well it looks like this
it's a straight line code that can be
pretty printed us see pretty easily and
it's probably not super easy to squint
at this and see interesting differences
between the 64-bit and 32-bit versions
for a particular prime number but at
least there's a lot more code on that
side as evidenced by the smaller font
size
because you need to use more registers
when they don't store as many bits and
we can generate 128-bit code getting
ready for more processors that that
support those registers directly and
it's almost no new effort a lot probably
likewise for 16-bit code and things like
that
our our framework is generic in those
decisions yeah
right the question is I'm talking about
registers but I'm just showing you C
code with as many local variables as you
like here so we depends on a register
allocator like usual most of these
variables quickly become dead as you
proceed down the code and so you you
mostly do manage to use registers for
all this stuff in fact the high level
algorithms are designed so that that's
the case you get the best performance
does that answer your question we have
the question is why the 32-bit side is
different
not sure which dimension you're talking
about but we have notice over there we
have 32-bit and 64-bit sized variables
maybe I'm the only one who can see that
since I'm so close this side we have
64-bit and 128-bit so that that's what
that's the difference okay they compiled
so for instance here I have a one in
twenty eight bit addition of two 64 bit
instructions and we use compiler
intrinsics to get the native processor
instructions for that which is really
important for some of these algorithms
yeah it's an addition that goes into two
registers we also have add with care
instructions for some algorithms and not
others so we do depend on a few
different flavors of processor of C
intrinsic that wouldn't normally be
around all right so another dimension of
success here is that we're now the curve
two five five one nine implementation in
Chrome and working on being likewise for
p2 five six so those numeric buzzwords
are the most popular elliptic curves
both in the the TLS standards P 256 is
still most widely used curve two five
five one nine is is like the hipster
curve that if you had a head of
popularity care if you realize is the
one effluence going to be using and it's
a lot simpler to implement which has
both pros and cons in that it's easier
for us to do first but it's more
impressive if you get P 256 also and we
have that proved it's just still being
integrated into the boring SSL library
that chrome uses and it'll first be out
there in chrome version 64 which I think
is in the in development stage now and
we'll switch to beta in the next few
weeks so let me go back and talk a bit
more about what really is going on on
this arithmetic and what are the
challenges so like I said different
prime moduli lead to dramatically
different implementation strategies to
get the best performance on the
processors that we have one prime number
that's very important to two to the 255
minus 19 it was designed by crypto
implementation experts to have good code
on commodity processors it fits a
general pattern that's been given many
names one of them is pseudo Mersenne
primes where you have a power of 2 minus
a small constant why do we care about
this why is this going to make the code
fast well a key operation that we need
to to come up with is modular reduction
which is basically the mod operator that
we're all used to from from math classes
and the trick is we know a lot of mod
operators are built into the hardware if
you happen to work with a power of two
than mod is very efficient to compute
but in crypto a part of the point is to
make things certain operations not
efficient to compute so we have a number
that's almost a power of two but
unfortunately almost doesn't count here
for getting good performance so we're
going to need to work to get mod to be
fast so here's an example of we might
think about this let's say I just did a
multiplication or something where the
output is naturally twice as wide as the
input operands and so I can take the the
output and think of it as a high order
word and a low order word we shift the
higher order word into place by
multiplying it by the right power of two
now I want to take this thing perform a
modulus operation to get it back down to
single width so let's do a little
algebra and I'll subtract
and see the this that small constant in
the appropriate place and then
distribute and now something nice has
happened we have this term here that's
multiplying by the modulus so goodbye to
that thing and now there's this kind of
clever thing that that's happened where
we've done a modular reduction where all
we need to do is multiply by a small
constant and add and now this sum is
probably though we don't it's not true
in all cases smaller than the modulus
and we've done a mod without using any
hardware mod instructions or anything
else slow we we just need addition and
multiplication and so sometimes we even
manage to do it without multiplication
since we know C we might implement that
as several additions if it's faster so
it's really crucial that we can do this
in practice to get good performance so
one thing we will do in our library is
generalize this trick and make our
compiler automatically use it where
appropriate so that was at the level of
the whole result of multiplication
assuming we have really big registers
which we don't so let's think about this
prime number and say we're gonna again
do a multiplication the the output of
multiplication would naturally be five
hundred ten bits wide and so we could
represent it on a 64-bit machine with
eight different registers and now let's
try to use that trick once we peaked
under the covers and seen how we break
numbers into registers so I've written
the the formula for turning one of these
lists of registers back into a big
number
and I've written it suggestively
splitting the registers into two halves
and multiplying by two to the 256 to
capture shifting the higher-order 1/2
into the appropriate position of the
answer unfortunately that says 2 to the
256 which is not 2 to the 255 so the
modular reduction trick that I just
showed doesn't apply and that means
somewhat counter-intuitively this
representation of big numbers is much
much slower than the the common ones on
commodity processors so this is not a
good choice the representation that's
actually used in practice
is to use 10 different registers that
only take up 51 bits even though we're
storing them in 64-bit registers so
we're kind of wasting bits but now we
can use this modular reduction trick by
the way at various points will allow the
registers to grow larger than 51 bits
and we'll carefully bound how much they
grow with each operation that eventually
will we'll carry and reduce down to get
back to the original representation so
the most widely used 64-bit
representations use this this trick and
then for 32-bit the the way it's usually
put is we'll take 20 registers each of
size 25 point 5 bits and get a
representation like this one and of
course it's a little expensive to get
fractional bit registers on commodity
processors so what that actually means
is let's to take a floor or a ceiling
operation in the appropriate places to
get these bit widths to be whole numbers
so now we get not only do we have some
choice in how many registers to split
the number into not only do we choose
how many of the bits and the registers
will we actually use we might actually
make non-uniform choices across the
different registers that we're using so
this is the standard 32 bit
implementation so at a high level what
we're doing is we're building a compiler
or a framework with a few different
words apply that is parametrized on
choices like this and given that any
choice guarantees to compile correct
code with with a theorem that the
arithmetic operations are actually
computing the the original whiteboard
level number theory stuff so our library
takes in your choice of representation
in that space of possibilities and spits
out fast quasi assembly code at the
moment we actually assume infinitely
many temporaries everything else is very
assembly code looking and you get a
proof the library parts better proved
once and for all parts of it are proof
generating so in a little more detail
what's going on inside that green oval
we have a library of
haskell like functional programs and
caulk that implement all the key
arithmetic and then we use partial
evaluation after you choose a particular
digit representation to specialize it to
your particular choice now we get
flatter functional programs that look
even more like assembly code and then we
do bounds inference and other compiler
optimizations to generate the actual
low-level code that comes out in the end
so here's an example of one of the kinds
of algorithms we need to deal with let's
look at multiplication modulo 2 to the
1:27 minus 1 a simpler version of the
prime that I was showing before so now
we might split each of the numbers into
3 different digits and they translate
back into big numbers like so so one way
to do this multiplication is just
compute all the cross terms between s
and T we get a bunch of terms like this
and I've lined them up suggestively here
because down the column as we see the
powers of two are very close to each
other so we can just add down the
columns and produce an output like so
and you can see in some places the
powers of two were a little off from
each other so we do extra multiplication
to compensate there and now we're almost
done except we have a double wide result
here meaning we have five digits where
we started out with only three in the
numbers we want to reduce this down to
being just three digits using process
called carrying and the way that works
is we notice the last two digits can we
can write the the formula to convert
back into one number like this where the
last two digits are shifted by
multiplying by two to the 127 and then
because 2 to the 127 is congruent to one
in the prime field we're working in we
can move those digits to appropriate
other positions for instance you three
move from all the way over there to here
and you four move to the second digit
and now we are back in the appropriate
three digit format so we write a
functional program that does this
generically for any choice of base
system representation we prove that
functional program correct once and for
all
so we can just specialize it to new
representation choices and automatically
know that you have a correct code but
it's not as easy as just saying that
there are some representation choices
that have a big effect on how how easy
the proofs are to write so you might
think we would want to formalize based
systems or how we divide numbers into
digits like this let's have a weight
function W that for each position in the
number representation tells us what we
multiply that position by to reconstruct
the original number so and we'll say the
first position zero needs to have weight
one that's the least significant digit
and all the other weights aren't need to
be nonzero so then when we have a list
like this we convert it back into a
number by multiplying each position by
The Associated weight just adding all
those together let's see so this turns
out to be rather hard to reason about
doing the proof so you're all whenever
you are doing a multiplication like on
this previous slide you get all these
these cross terms and you have to ask
yourself is the weight of this digit
already in my base system or do I need
to do some sort of conversion to get it
to match what my base system support so
for instance this two to the 85 versus
two to the 86 one of those is going to
be not in the the original base system
and we have to do some special work to
convert between weights of digits and
other little things like that we're just
building up in complexity when we were
writing the code and doing the proofs so
instead we decided on a different
representation called associational
where we represent numbers as lists of
pairs of digits and the kind of static
weights that are associated with them so
for instance if we represent the number
234 with the usual decimal system then
it gets translated to that list over
there that just has the digits I think I
meant but uh yeah something a little
something's a little wrong here this
looks like a a 2 in the last position
instead of before anyway we take the
digits and we pair them with their their
weights which are powers of 10 and
get that list the question is if one of
the digits is zero do we include an
explicit entry for that in the list and
I think we do because usually the actual
digit values are variables rather than
constants so we don't know what zero in
advance
all right um but we we're going to
generalize this and allow a lot of
flexibility in in how we split numbers
up and we're going to allow lists like
this which may even have duplicate
weight so for instance we could take
this list and add something else
multiply by a hundred and we're not
going to fix the weights in advance
because in intermediate stages during
algorithms all sorts of strange
temporary weights might pop up and we
want to be prepared for any of those so
given a list like this that's pretty
easy to write a coq functional program
that translates the list back into one
big number which we we use to state the
correctness properties the actual
running code never does this we don't
have registers big enough to store these
numbers but it's a very simple map
followed by a fold right kind of thing
which I'm sure any of you could have
written in your sleep and but the
consequences of this are really great
for simplicity of the the proofs so for
instance we want to implement addition
does anyone have an implementation of an
addition in mind for this representation
it becomes really trivial now yeah it's
just this concatenation and so we can
just prove that the evaluation of a
concatenated list is the sum of the two
values of the original lists and this is
a big simplification over what we do
would need to do with the static based
system approach and it has a pretty
short cough proof too so to do
multiplication we just want to compute
all the cross terms between the two
lists and that's pretty straightforward
and so we can define multiplication like
this it's a we take a map and a flat map
and put them together in the right way
and you can prove a theorem like this
one that multiplication of this kind
really corresponds to multiplication of
the usual kind with pushing evaluation
through the
operation and that has a pretty short
proof as well and really all the other
arithmetic operations we need go
similarly smoothly to this but Bosley
reduction is a little more complicated
not too much more so remember I talked
about this trick where we we reduce the
modular reduction operation to just
multiplying and adding and we can
generalize that to the full space of
base systems where we need an operation
called split that takes one of these
lists and breaks it into the terms whose
whose weights are above a threshold and
below a threshold and that turns out to
be easier to write to we just use a
classic list partition operation that
checks it looks at the weights and sees
which ones are 0 mod the the amount
we're splitting by and then keeps the
high part of that partition the same and
then reduces the low part where
everything is is divisible by this
weight actually does the division and
then we're good there and then the
reduce operation that we need performs a
split and then does the multiply and
adds because remember we implement add
with just concatenation of lists so this
too is quite straightforward but there
has to be a catch right because we're
working with this crazy representation
in the end we want the actual running
assembly level code to be using a fixed
digit representation so the way that
works is we write code like this one
which takes inputs that are actually
using dependent types do to enforce say
this tuple ZN type is a n tuple of
elements of Z and we first take the
regular representation convert each of
the inputs into the associational form
then do the computation in our nice
representation and then go back out from
associational to the normal
representation you might be worried
looking at this code that we're going to
have runtime overhead of constantly
converting back and forth between
formats the idea is for a given function
that's present in the code in the end we
only convert once at the beginning of
the code and once at the end and we're
going to use partial evaluation to room
of all the overhead of this conversion
such that our proofs are a lot easier by
the fact that everything all the reason
thing in the middle here is
straightforward and we will also need to
prove that these two associational and
from associational operations are
correct they have to do a little bit of
arithmetic to choose the right way to
convert when you have an input term
whose weights don't quite match the ones
you're looking for but we do that once
we prove that once and then the other
code in its proofs follow this form and
I'm pretty straightforward to verify so
in other words let's say we have the
example of multiply or some other
arithmetic function
it's parametrized over the bit widths of
the digits that come in over the actual
values of the digits and then it
produces the multiplication we think of
the bit widths as a compile-time fixed
parameter and the actual digits as a
runtime varying parameter so we do
specialization to just think of this as
a curried function so that just passing
it one of the arguments and not the
others produces a term that stands
for the representation specialized
multiplication and then we just reduced
that with partial evaluation and until
it gets rid of all the overhead of the
the generality and caulks a really nice
platform for doing this because the
specialised stage is just partially
applying a curried function the reduced
stage is just calling standard term
reduction features that use lambda
calculus rules to reduce until suddenly
the code looks like assembly more or
less so these state these steps are not
only are they easy and caulk but for
those in the know about type theory
based proof assistance they basically
produce proof terms that are essentially
just restating the the problem you don't
need to do any explicit pretty proof
manipulations these steps are built into
the logic as automatically applied for
you whenever you need them so here's an
example of the the end product of that
approach so I'm to find a particular
base system this is the example I gave
of that popular prime where you need to
split it into 20 different digits each
based on a
we're alternating between two different
bid widths and this function up top
specifies that so I stayed a proof
goal saying please find me an inhabitant
of this set given two tuples of width 10
oh so apparently we only have 10 I guess
this might be a simplified version of
that example give me F G which is
another tuple of width 10 where when I
evaluate it in this bit this choice of
widths we get out the same thing as if I
evaluated the two inputs and multiplied
those together in our particular modulus
and then drumroll please I run the
framework and out pops this code
probably should have introduced a bug on
purpose and asked anybody if they can
catch it but this is pretty nice flat
looking code that can be turned into C
like code by just introducing names for
the intermediate computations and all
these numbers like 38 and 19 popped into
existence at the right spots and no new
proofs needed to be written for this to
work but we do get a guarantee that this
is a correct realization of all that so
we have some tactics that given
this statement of a proof goal will
automatically do what's needed to get to
this point yeah every operation is
carefully written to stay in this
particular representation of yeah to me
that if you convert to associational
form and then go back that you will also
always stay in that form got it so the
question is given this framework we've
set up that is so it's so flexible about
the widths of digit different points how
can we be sure that the code we generate
will actually stay committed to one
representation the answer is the general
framework does not ensure that but we
heuristically choose the right
instantiations of its parameters so that
in practice
happens and so it's at least true if you
get that heuristic choice wrong you
don't get functionally incorrect code
out but you might get really slow code
so you can even do genetic search
through a space of parameters and
benchmark everything and keep the fast
ones so that you can get good
performance without baking in to the
formal side
what good performance means about two
slides from now that that's when I know
the bound that none of these over flow
which is important so could we someday
prove performance results it seems very
believable given that we're basically
doing straight line code here how hard
can it be
optimality so prove that can we prove
that there is no better implementation
of this algorithm on this processor i I
have thought about doing that because we
also work on processor verification so
we could look at the Vera log code for
the processor and try to prove that but
I have no concrete ideas on what the
proof strategy would be sounds like fun
though right
we do have carrots uber in our library
but it's not it's not being used here I
think yeah
I think carrots uber turned out to be
not so bad in this this funky
representation but I don't remember the
details do you expect to get a code that
corresponds to pretty much yeah we
question is will we expect to get the
same code that the experts are writing
by hand what tends to happen is it's not
literally the same code but it's a one
line proof in Cocke to establish it's
the same code the instructions are in
different orders which do have
consequences for register allocation and
that sort of stuff when it's still an
open problem how to automatically make
those choices in a very efficient way
there there are no deep differences in
our code versus the handwritten code all
right there's one other catch that shows
up in partial evaluation which this
example was too simple to need sometimes
we have common sub terms within a big
term like this not so many here because
sort of by construction we're always
getting these cross products of
different terms of the input but
sometimes we need to preserve term
structure so let me give an example well
here I'm just trying to motivate the
idea sometimes you want to generate code
with let's in it and have those be
preserved throughout the evaluation down
to flat code so imagine the let's in
this simple example were built binding
variables that needed to be mentioned
multiple times though in this case to
keep it straightforward I'm only having
each let being mentioned once this is a
simplified case of an addition algorithm
that is just component wise adding the
digits between two inputs and by the way
you might notice this simple code
doesn't do carrying across digits but
actually many real algorithm to set
things up very carefully so that you
don't need to do carrying with it with
every add and only after a few you have
accumulated enough extra bits in your
registers that you then do some work but
imagine we're trying to add
to list using this function and now I
want to specialize this code to the case
of three digits in each input there are
some three six values that are not known
at compile time and I just tell caulk
evaluate this functional program in the
usual way unfortunately we get this kind
of ugly thing which doesn't look like
assembly all the let's are nested inside
of the list cons operations so the way
we get around that is unfortunately but
it works well in the end we write most
of our code in continuation passing
style so that here's the CPS version of
add lists where say the recursive call
is is in tail position and we built a
new continuation and standard and stuff
like that and then when we try to do the
same kind of reduction on the lists of
length three with unknown values then it
just reduces to the right point so it
looks really straightforward here it's
kind of a pain in our code base we wrote
everything in CPS and direct style
improved equivalence and the actual
normalization only happens in CPS to get
proper sharing of common sub terms took
us a long time to figure this out by the
way so alright because we've told caulk
not to do the let in lining rule of
reduction but to do all the others or an
appropriate set of others yeah it's kind
of magic I have I haven't I don't have a
great description of why I think this
trick is sort of well known in the
partial evaluation world but
oh by the way I forgot to repeat the
question which was why basically why
does this help I think was the question
and and then Clement partly answered the
question and the weight right so okay I
guess a sort explanation of why this
works is with natural reduction rules we
do all the let's before we start
building the list and that's what makes
this work and by the way you might worry
hey there's still a list left left in
this program that's not a very idea
Matic C program but will actually take
this operation and compose it with
others in practice and all the lists
will reduce away in a larger program
I think the answer is yes - the question
was getting the top version to work
nicely in Cocke would require caulk to
do some some work to hoist let's for us
we spent a month or more trying to get
that to work and it just wasn't worth
the effort so that's why we switched to
CPS and we were trying to write a proof
by reflection tactic that does that for
us
but oh this is much nicer once you get
past writing everything in CPS and
proving it once alright so one other
dimension of complication I should
mention is there are two major
implementation strategies for arithmetic
in this world called unsaturated and
saturated arithmetic in unsaturated you
intentionally put digits and registers
that have bits to spare beyond what
you'll actually try to fit in there and
then you you have to periodically use
carrying to reduce things down to fit
again and so our library to support this
strategy needs to be parametrized not
just on digit division strategies but
also on the when to carry and between
which digits so that's that's another
parameter and we prove correctness for
any such choice the key point here we
don't prove lack of overflows once and
for all that's going to be on the next
slide that comes later in compilation
and then the alternative is saturated
arithmetic where we fully utilize to
register big widths at all times yeah
career you have to reason about
interrupts and signals or assume the
thigo s always restores every single
okay seems like it's very new so the
question is when when we depend on
compiler intrinsics for operations like
ad with carry do we have to worry that
our program gets interrupted between
that instruction and a later one that
uses the carry bit I think we assume the
compiler understands its intrinsics well
enough to avoid that the carry bit goes
into a regular C variable and so this
usual guarantee should apply there it is
worth mentioning that the popular C
compilers often do a terrible job of
optimizing programs that use carry flags
explicitly they they like to spill to
carry flags into memory all the time
when when it's it's crazy from the
standpoint of the assembly code you'd
naturally right so yeah but that is a
compiler problem even independently of
formal methods that would be nice to
have solved in a uniform way right yeah
I've probably said everything for this
slide okay so now let's actually start
discharging this obligation about
overflow and making sure we don't have
it so imagine in earlier stages we
compiled this expression which is a
somewhat optimized version of some sort
of program as free variables x and y and
what we do at this point in our pipeline
is we reified this to a syntax tree in a
type to find inside of caulk where the
formal semantics whoops and then we do
some constant folding to reduce it as
much as possible well we still have this
nice algebraic style of expression then
we flatten it into a form where we
introduce a name for every intermediate
computation that's a roughly the level
we were looking at before and there by
the way that might have already been
some let's and
a starting point but I'm just assuming
we didn't have any here and now we're
going to infer balance and this is just
abstract interpretation with intervals
though there are a few twists so we
assume bounds for the all the free
variables in the term and we're just
gonna push those through all the
operations and infer balance for all the
intermediate terms and then based on the
bounds we've inferred we can see let's
see C needs at least 52 bits but add it
the upper bound is adding a few powers
of two but that's a relief it's still
less than 2 to the 64 and D similar sort
of thing happens so we could put both of
these in 64-bit integers and the main
pain for us implementing this analysis
was proving bounds for bitwise operators
on negative numbers for what it's worth
we had to do something sound in that
case we do need bitwise operators on
negative numbers for popular algorithms
to get the best performance so we do
this this and this analysis and it pops
out some code and by the way we're
generating a sts in Cocke for this final
phase but we want a pretty printed at C
and the way we do that is Jason one of
the students working on this project
wrote a script that registers something
like a thousand different caulk macros
so that caulk itself pretty prints its
own code as C it's very black magic e
and then we feed that to the normal C
compilers to finish the process so other
parts I don't have time to go into more
detail about but remember early on I
said we start out with two-dimensional
points for elliptic curves and we reason
about replacing them with
four-dimensional points and probably we
have other examples that are even
fancier who we built some new clock
tactics to justify all that and we
proved all the popular point formats
something like 10 of them and they're
mostly automatic proofs after a few
months spent on basically a tactic that
does things computer algebra systems do
but in a proof generating way and we
have a whole menu of arithmetic
operations that are in this library
including finding inverses
exponentiation square roots and going
out of our strange and codings back into
standard wire format encoding
and several of these have their own
dimensions of choices from small menus
of operations like exponentiation or
square roots in particular there are
like two different recipes for square
roots depending on the number of
theoretic properties of your prime so we
define both of those and you can pick
which one you want without having to
worry about breaking the soundness
alright so how did we evaluate the
actual performance effectiveness of this
approach well first I'll say we've about
thirty-eight thousand lines of code in
our full library about half of that is
generic math stuff that would fit in the
coq standard library conceptually very
little work very little code is needed
to instantiate to a new prime modulus
and I'll show an experiment justifying
that in particular we wrote a Python
script under 3,000 lines of code that
examines your your prime number and tell
it and makes a guess about the best
parameters and importantly the prime
number needs to be written in a
suggestive form like this where the
actual where you break it into additions
and subtractions with powers of two
influences how the heuristic works but
this is the way crypto implementation
people are used to writing things so
that they can sort of look into it and
see the essence of the write
optimizations to use and this script
that generates the parameters is not
trusted the worst thing that happens if
it's wrong is you compilation my time
out but if compilation to finish this
you're guaranteed to get correct code
might not be efficient code but you can
auto-tune with many different parameters
and pick the ones that finish and
actually give you performant code so we
did a little bit of that we needed to
get a list of different moduli to try
for arithmetic so what we did was we
scraped the most popular mailing list
for elliptic curves and we processed the
text and found everything that was a
prime number and that that gave us about
80 different prime numbers and luckily
only a few of them turned out to be
complete nonsense posted by people who
were new to the mailing list and didn't
understand elliptic curves but those
would time out when we tried to compile
them they were maybe like three of those
or something so then we automatically
built both 64-bit and 32-bit versions
for all these Prime's as well as
building versions for the two main
arithmetic strategies saturated and
unsaturated and then we would just free
to platform we'd keep the faster one and
so that leads to these results here are
the ones for 60
4-bit arithmetic it was kind of hard to
figure out what are we benchmarking
against as a baseline because most prime
field arithmetic is specialized to
particular algorithms but what we
decided to do is take the new multi
precision integer library which is
probably the most popular generic big
number C library out there and see how
much faster you can get your code to be
by using our library versus using this
off-the-shelf C library where we been
the C code we'd recompile it with a
macro for the preprocessor macro set for
the prime number but otherwise it would
it was mostly runtime specialization two
different prime numbers but this library
in the last few years I think did start
doing compile time code generation to
specialize things to moduli so it does
take advantage of that so the bottom
line here is is what we get oh the
x-axis is the number of bits in the
prime modulus and then these two other
curves here for two versions of the GMP
library one where we say you must
produce constant time code that does not
leak of secret data values through
timing and the other one we say alright
feel free to these optimizations that
break constant time which is not OK for
crypto but which gives that library an
inherent advantage and you can see even
for this bottom curve which is allowed
to break constant time we were ranging
from between about one and a half times
faster to ten times faster in some cases
and this is completely automatic of a
script scrapes all the primes and does
this for you so no new coding work no
new proof work and also we run the same
thing for 32-bit code which we run on an
Android phone and get pretty similar
kinds of results going up to a
neighborhood of ten times faster for
many of these curbs compared to live GMP
that sounds right but then also
apparently we're seeing so the
suggestion was we look for four points
on the x-axis that are multiples of the
base word size may be the interesting
thing is let's see
you're basically pointing out these
discontinuities up there okay yeah that
could be true
what stands out for me are these points
where suddenly our code does a lot worse
I'm not sure what's happening there
there's another question yeah that's
kind of weird
we're not sure what why that is it
probably just so the question is why are
the non constant time ones often faster
or slower than the constant time ones
probably just because GMP isn't tested
on Android phones too much we we had to
work hard enough to get it to build that
I can sort of believe that isn't
happening much we couldn't get the C++
version to build for instance within our
patience budget all right okay so this
is like all the primes we found on this
mailing list there are also a few
Prime's that are really important
practice where we wanted to compare
against not just GMP but also the best
assembly code out there so here's part
of the curve two five five one nine code
base you'd need for TLS 1.3 for the
preferred cipher Suites at least and
here's our code I'll explain why there
are two lines for it we're basically
listing these different implementations
by how many CPU cycles they take and our
code is doing all right where the
generated C which is the the most
literal interpretation of the pipeline
I've been talking about was something
like 20% off from the best assembly code
to start out with now what we did to try
to understand what we were missing to be
faster is we looked at I think it was
this C program which is the best-known C
program or maybe we look directly at the
assembly I'm not sure and then took the
code
someone else had written and translated
into caulk in the same form as a
functional program and then proved that
that form is is equal to ours
extensional e and so that got us like 10
percent better performance and my
conclusion from all that is that what
we're really missing is good instruction
scheduling and register allocation which
the experts are doing by hand as they
write this code so that's one of our
directions for future work to build a
compiler that does those in the right
way it turns out clang and GCC actually
do really bad register allocation for
this kind of code and you can get a
factor of 2 and performance in many
cases by hand writing the assembly code
and doing instruction scheduling and
register allocation yourself but it
would be nice to have a compiler for
that we also measured performance of our
our P 256 implementation this is the
most common elliptic curve in TLS
significantly harder to implement
efficiently on commodity processors
which is why the other one was invented
but here you can see we're like roughly
twice the number of CPU cycles versus
the best-known assembly code and on this
slide and the previous one like everyone
else who works in the space we at least
beat the performance of OpenSSL
cross-platform C code which sounds
impressive at first until you realize no
one uses this code in practice because
it's too slow but we're at least
reasonable against that baseline all
right so the next steps we want to
tackle here one I was just mentioning is
some of the last phases of compilation
really deserve good compiler support
even if we forget about proofs namely we
want better register allocation and
instruction scheduling so we don't have
to hand modify the last stages and what
popped out of our compiler and we think
it's okay to write some sort of really
expensive
maybe random search based version of
this that you let run overnight for your
important crypto algorithms we'd like to
expand our scope to more of the crypto
primitives from TLS and and other
protocols and in general try to do more
of the parts of TLS inside caulk with
code derivation based strategies as
opposed to write the code and verify it
strategies and they're also seem to be
good matches with other kinds of crypto
especially emerging kinds like lattice
based cryptography
apparently there's still a lot of
experimentation but how we should use
lattices and crypto primitives so it
would be nice to have a compiler that
takes each such new idea and
automatically builds fast code for all
the platforms that are out there and I
think I'll stop here with our github URL
where you can download this and give it
a try we tried that a little bit so far
we maybe we should try more the question
was why don't we just talk to the people
who are hand writing the code to get the
heuristics out of their brains that we
put into compilers for go up for
register allocation and similar stuff I
don't think the experts have the level
of introspective knowledge to just tell
us what the algorithm is and we haven't
been successful yet at at extracting it
but we'll keep trying
it's a moment I'm betting more on random
search based approaches being being
effective we'll see yeah vector
instructions have been on our list to
support since the start we don't know
how it'll work exactly
we'd like to to do some manipulations at
the level of functional programs that
defined appropriate units to group
together but no concrete insights to
share at this time it is important to
get the best performance on particular
processors but we haven't gotten there
yet
I think it might be handling of carry
flags GCC likes to spill carry flags to
the stack and the Intel compiler is
reasonable so the question is why
weren't the experts already scripting
the work that we're doing automatically
even without the proofs it still is
still a big advantage and the reason is
they didn't think it could be done I
guess when we talk to the people who've
designed all these these protocols these
primitives they're they're pretty
surprised that you can general has it's
that it's just a functional program that
embodies all the algorithms they've been
figuring out well they already do that
even in open SSL and veil does that kind
of well they just write scripts that do
the loop unrolling for them that that
part works but but as far as I know
there are no scripts prior to ours that
are generalized in either the prime
modulus or the target hardware
architecture they get rewritten for each
one or at least they're significant
implementation effort for each new
variation because you have proofs you
are emboldened to actually search for
this stuff uh-huh cuz you can just wrote
a script and you just like here's a
implementation and it happens to be
faster than the other one on some test
vector you know that it's actually
so I think that the proofs are innate
and enabler right oh yeah the other
point is I think so Hackl star is also
doing this kind of meta programming to
generate implementations that are
advertised by a template for the
representation of the big nom I think
what you're doing that's maybe more than
what Michael is doing is that I hope a
code derives the operations all the
operations except the modular reduction
generically biomatter programming yeah
and then you have to provide just the
modular production but I think Hackl has
in hackls defense they they ensure that
they always stay in this particular
template that was provided whereas given
the remark that little discussion that
we had I mean I think yours into in in
the intermediate states you may actually
depart from the original right so just
to repeat both the previous remark for
people following along at home and this
this other remark first one was having
proofs of correctness in Boldin's the
programmer to try new generation
strategies and maybe the people who
didn't have proofs in the bad old days
didn't try these strategies for that
reason the second remark was that the
Hackel star library is generic over the
prime modulus except in the modular
production code and it's set up to
guarantee in the appropriate sense that
you stick in the representation that the
implementer would want and is true that
our library does not guarantee that and
again I'll just mention all the cases
where you're outside that representation
only occur at compile time and get
reduced away to cases where you do stay
inside the representation as long as you
chose the right parameters but you might
not have
the question is are we planning to go to
assembly yes we are writing a new
verified compiler for a C like language
that we are planning to connect into
this and that it's pretty easy to do
that for this code and it's very close
to assembly already but but we want to
expand the scope to include loops and
other things that some of those related
projects have already tackled we can
choose random parameters to
cryptographic algorithms and hope we hit
on something useful yeah I don't
actually know what goes into deciding
which one of these Prime's is the right
one to use but I think it could be a
huge mistake to find the ones where the
right operations are fast
could be want cracking your your
cryptography to be slow the hard part
here is you need to find parameters
where the right operations are fast and
where a certain other operations are
really slow and it's hard to hard to use
testing to ensure things are really slow
they just didn't have the right the
question is what made certain prime is
posted on the mailing was bad and it was
that they didn't have the right
structure for these optimizations to
work
I had probably I'm not sure you did okay
and it's also the case that sometimes
the same Prime can be usefully expressed
in multiple different formulas and one
formula is best for 64-bit one formula
is best for 32-bit and so we had to use
that to get the right behavior in some
cases
[Applause]